the Eastern Cape Province of South
Africa is home to the cosa people one of
the nation's largest tribes the Cosa
live in the modern world but they
maintain ancient customs including one
by which boys become men it's a rite of
passage that starts with pain every
summer boys are circumcised painted
white and isolated in remote Hut's where
they spend weeks healing
always a difficult and dangerous
experience the tradition has become even
more so here in the city initiates crowd
into all available space hygiene is poor
an infection is common some cosa boys
die trying to become men
the Mahal a family is sending one of its
own in the journey to mangle Tondo is
enjoying his last day as a boy and what
are you about to pee and and what do you
like is something you don't clean so
weird because I hear lot of guys go to
hospital the whole poster community will
participate in this rite of passage the
men load up materials to build Tondo a
hut and bush his family chose an
isolated site at the outskirts of town
distracted by the hut construction Hondo
doesn't notice that the surgeon has
arrived
traditional surgeons have no formal
training but some have more skill than
others there will be no ceremony before
the circumcision it comes with the speed
of an ambulance
without warning the surgeon steps
forward to remove Hondo's foreskin
ignoring the pain Tondo shouts out Xhosa
tradition holds that foreskins must be
buried to keep sorcerers from using them
in witchcraft the surgeon is also
careful to clean the blade to reduce the
risk of transmitting diseases such as
AIDS when the hut is read he'll be left
here alone for weeks now the real danger
ratandas initiation begins in the coming
weeks he faces the risk of infection
even gangrene and until he's healed he
can eat no fresh food and drink no water
to loose elements the initiates must not
drink water because the water comes out
of the penis and makes the wound wet so
it doesn't heal properly should
infection strike he'll have to choose
between getting care and remaining true
to his tribe if he seeks medical
attention the Cosa will never accept him
as a man the white clay paint marks
Tondo as an initiate
he'll wear it throughout his transition
but right now his mind is on water which
he is forbidden to drink sometimes
initiates face dehydration so severe it
can sicken or even kill Tondo is allowed
to sustain himself with only a liquid
rain from
after a weeks condo is well enough to
drink water and he's allowed to visit
with other initiates whose huts are
nearby their experiences here in the
bush will bind them together in the Cosa
community
one month after Tondo left the men make
one last trip to his Hut gone is the
white clay pain of a boy now Tondo
undergoes a centuries-old custom a
coating of fat but instead of the animal
fat his ancestors he's anointed with
margarine from the supermarket the
entire community gathers to celebrate in
return everyone escorts him home
neighbors join the throng his
achievement is there by respecting
tradition and prevailing over hardship
Tondo has proven himself a man red clay
marks his new status he is now eligible
for marriage and other rights of
adulthood he has earned his place in the
Cosa nation